there's a concept um called the infinite
game
um a finite game is something with known
players fixed rules and it agreed upon
objective
you know baseball football there's a
beginning middle and end
and then there's something called an
infinite game um where there are known
and unknown players
the rules are changeable and the
objective is to keep playing to
perpetuate the game
um what's interesting is we are
completely surrounded
by infinite games there's no such thing
as winning marriage
um there's no such thing as winning
therapy
um there's no such thing as winning life
you know if you make more money than all
your friends you don't win
and there's definitely no such thing as
winning business they are infinite games
and there are many other infinite games
that that in which we are uh players uh
every single day of our lives the
problem is is too many people
play in some of these games as if they
were finite games
if you think about how too many uh ceos
or or
people in business talk about their
business they talk about being number
one
being the best beating our competition
based on what metrics based on what time
frames and no one else has agreed to
those things which means
there's no such thing and so what i
learned is that when we play
finite game when we play infinite games
with finite rules eventually we run out
of the will and the resources to play
the resource is obvious you go bankrupt
but will is sometimes we burn out and i
just don't want to do it anymore
so you might make tons of money but
you're just like i hate this and i don't
want to go to work every day
and so we have to learn to adjust
how we lead our organizations
so that we play the appropriate way for
the uh for the appropriate game
[Music]